so so but that's that's catholicism so
there's
there's this thing sometimes i just
can't take how funny you are because i
just want to throw something at your
head
yeah i can't take it and then here's a
good graphic song that i remember from
when i was in second grade i remember
being in the
same thighs had an upper church and a
lower church and we would we would
always have we would always go down to
the lower church and i'll never forget
on wednesdays
my mom would always make me a salami
sandwich and i could never eat it
i could never eat it on wednesdays i
could never eat it because
we would go to the lower church mass at
11 30 midday mass 11 30 a.m from 11 30
to 12 and then we would eat our lunch
but there was a uh a big and the lower
church had this huge
um crucifix statue and it had jesus's
like guts ripped open and like blood
dripping down and it looked like the
salami was about to eat
so i couldn't eat it yeah so so um
because it was basically the enemy's
food it was well well that but it just
it was just gross i was looking at this
gory figure of jesus
and then the salami looked like his guts
coming out and we used to have to sing
this song every wednesday night
i don't remember all the words but this
was the chorus were you
there when they crucified my lord
oh sometimes it causes me
to tremble tremble
tremble then the next verse was were you
there when they nailed him
to the tree
[Music]
sometimes it causes me
to tremble tremble
tremble and then it goes back and forth
for that so i had to look at him
look at jesus dying think about him
being nailed to the tree and then eat a
salami sandwich
couldn't do it that sounds like a fun
time for a seven-year-old
i was seven eight nine years old singing
that song and my mother would make me
sing it out loud
like on the weekends what songs did you
learn before you watch cartoons yeah
before i watch cartoons she would say
make sure you sing the
nail jesus to the tree song now i
noticed two things while you were
singing yeah
one that's [ __ ] scary yeah i mean
it's halloween
with a body did that sound scary to you
even honestly yeah that was
that was that was weird that's weird i
feel like things would get weird
google exactly if you can i don't know
if google were you there when they
crucified my lord's song
or were you there when they nailed it to
the tree store because i'm sure i'm
forgetting some powerful lyrics because
i'm not scared of ghosts but if i saw
10 kids walking at me slowly singing
that song
yeah i'm running the other way yeah i'm
getting under the covers
yeah that was scary so i noticed that
and the other thing i noticed was you
have
no talent for singing yeah absolutely
zero you're a talented kid in many other
areas
but i cannot say you just cannot say it
was brutal
fumes i haven't heard this song in a
while and i may start to cry again
because i'm thinking of [ __ ] please
memories from father bill for the only
piece of property that he had in the
world
and that was the road he was like a man
were you there when they
crucified my lord
this is it but it's different were you
there
when they crucified my
[Music]
it causes me
[Music]
can you come into my back room and get
my rope
[Music]
chris is tearing up oh my god is this
tough for you
a little bit i'm thinking about sister
burn and dance sister seraphine
stop saying real [ __ ] names chris
podcast
[Music]
[ __ ] thinking about wow
i'm thinking about all the nuns all my
friends they're coming no we're just
doing this we're trying to activate your
memory
[ __ ] is there a priest penis by your
head anymore no but no
remember is anything coming back
yeah they were trying to trigger his
ptsd right now wait
where did i make up were you there when
they nailed him to the tree
here
they just said it yeah johnny cass is
the best
it's hard to imagine that there was
times are you there when the stone was
rolled away i forgot that part yeah
[Laughter]
yeah if rafael de luca makes a [ __ ]
beat of this
yes oh we gotta play raphael deluca's
new song oh yeah we'll do that for the
people at the end
[Music]
there's no question that's at some point
many times in history
a priest called a couple kids into his
back chambers
and put this song on as he was disrobing
liked that scene in pulp fiction yeah
and he just closed the door and brought
out the [ __ ]
he was yeah unfortunately a few priests
probably more like get out you know the
clink and they just knock out you hear
that and it's just black and black
that's what it is yeah hit the tea cup i
think there's been a couple of
unfortunately there's been a couple of
kids on their knees throwing around a
priest meat in their mouth while this
song is blasting in the background
i mean just what it is it's what it is
i'm a catholic kid i can say that it's
just true
it's just what it is we really hope you
enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild